so as you can see we've got plenty of
visitors here today from us much more
than what we have had in the past I bet
you all knew that this was happening we
had plenty of notice so over here we
have mrs. yang you know me already I
miss lately I've mr. Wu we have mr.
Johnson and we have mr. Arland far side
there who you met on Friday and we are
here today to introduce our project that
we've been telling you about which is
our systemic base project so that we're
all working together with you what we
want to do today is we would like to
take the opportunity for the other
teachers to introduce themselves because
you haven't had a lot of time with them
yet and then from there we're going to
introduce our design brief that we've
been briefly discussing and the
situation so that we know how to move
forward from there anyone have any
questions so far
No who wants to start on I'm gonna jump
in if mr. Owen can plug in so I can use
my visual in a second or neither are you
very good thank you all refreshments
that I might leave those from you cause
they're people seeing these over the
loss didn't love it good afternoon
everyone it's a real delight for me to
be here with you especially being it you
know not just that I hope to come up
with the name for the project that I'm
leaving a year 11 taught maths class
right now and read capable hands because
there was no way that I was going to
miss what's happening today and the
launch that we're gonna be involved now
just to give you a bit of background
about myself I went to study a Bachelor
education Bachelor of Science and resi
so this whole stem idea I'm heavily
invested in I'm very keen from you guys
I understand why that's
well for you as well okay said right at
the beginning encouraged side by this
project I want to give you three reasons
why I'm excited
firstly a reason a bit about me secondly
a reason about the project itself and
thirdly a reason about you no question
okay so let me start with me because
that's that's my style pay for
everything because I'm very subjective
mystical man when I was at school I was
fairly good at math and that was the end
of the story like I was very good at
doing all the processes and
understanding it and that sort of came
naturally to me by a very little
appreciation of the power that
mathematics has to understand how well
and helped us to manipulate it as well
you just had to think about the things
you've learned over maths at last nine
ten years of your schooling
the statuses you know say quadratic
equations quadratic greens we've worked
through preventing pleasures for at
least a couple of minutes quadratic
equations unlock the path of flying
objects through the air
think about statistical analysis
statistical analysis is what allows us
to take mind-boggling amounts of data
and find patterns and meaning into our
conclusions even the really really
seemingly irrelevant stuff has to do
with something I'll give you exactly
prime numbers who-knows-where prime
number is I don't gonna ask you to give
me an example I just want to see you get
a show of hands how much explanation as
you okay it's like yeah for those of you
who didn't raise your hands it's fine
but easiest way to think of a prime
number is a number that doesn't divide
up nicely okay so picture pizza get your
pizza if I were to be really
in cut this fits into one two four five
six seven pieces if I count that number
of pieces is really hard to divide up
you can't divide it evenly between two
people or three people or four people
you can't really divide up under any
meaningful number of people unless
you've got seven of them or a master do
some cutting so seven is crying of
course a number which isn't crying salon
giving example we know it's not prime
eight I heard six it's easy because you
can do it into two groups of four okay
what do Prime's have to do with anything
it seemed like the most you know who
actually cuts a pizza into seven base no
one right but actually prime numbers are
things you use every day okay think
about it every time you log on to a
website or you buy an app or sewing fun
or you connect to the wireless anytime
you put a pasta or a credit card number
to something a prime number is the fuel
of the engine that's mathematically
keeping your data secure every time
actually there's a single new massive
prime number and that's the only thing
that stand between you and all the
hackers of the world numbers well I hope
you do right even if you don't
understand anything
so I made that discovery about the
connection between maths and our world I
made after I left school actually when I
was training to become a teacher but you
will make that discovery in this course
okay which leads me on to a second thing
I'm really excited about is my second
reason why I'm saying that course the
nature of the course itself right now
even the very fact that the four of us
and mr. Johnson are here in this room is
a literal embodiment of the fact that
we've been working together
collaborating for months to plan his
project and to make a reality and that's
the way things are in the real world
there isn't clean there aren't clean
lines between maths and science in
technology engineer they're all one they
all fit together not only that but this
is why I have this visual heat in
mainstream maths you are used to
learning things and being challenged to
do things like this okay so let's have a
look over even doing I'm gonna pick out
the exercises that Mike Ross was doing
today
okay okay Donnie perpetually here we go
Cinco interest now let's pick out a
question like this okay if you can read
it there you've seen hundreds of
questions like this simple interest
earned on an investment thirty five
thousand dollars for years three point
six percent okay now here's the the
wonderful thing about this question you
know that there are exactly three pieces
of information you need to solve this
question and you know because they're
the three that have been given to you
and that's nice that's convenient it's
handy for a formula but it's not like
the real world in the real world you
don't get told there are three pieces of
information we need to know and you need
to fit them into these three holes in
the real world you have to work out what
the information is that you need to know
and then you have to go and find it and
then you have to work out how to combine
it all together and that's what this
this course is going to show you and
develop the skills that we have for
asking questions mathematically and
scientifically and design work how
reason about me a reason about the
structure of the course I'm the great
new way of learning that it introduces
lastly a reason about you I'm sooo
excited when I look around this room
because you have a think is intuitive
the future the skills that you learn
today here in this classroom or shape
the world tomorrow that is intensely
exciting for me and Ferris the teachers
for it so I'm excited that project hope
you guys out to you as you discover a
bit more about
tonight why I am miss yang and peach
physics and chemistry in the school and
what mr. rules say is very true the
physics chemistry and engineering and
they even ask we all linked together in
this way one bit of my background why I
am in this project or why you people are
so important okay you people are really
important because I got to leave my
aircraft on that's I'm a women are they
really important I have to take that one
period out to see you people I'm really
excited to be here not bit of myself
oh I'm major in physics the Miss Ida
pure and Applied Physics in a unique and
not many comes so girls young really
into engineering that's really great
physics is the subject as requiring
engineering so we hope that you picked
up this subject and with your math
skills and your technology skills you're
going to face the wall and be the future
for the we have biomedical engineering
we have so many different courses that's
really challenging and very exciting but
we need to get you people interested
first that's why I'm here and I think
mr. Lewis spoken a lot about the
linkages between science and medicine
and another subject and as as in school
always interested in problem solving
like you people in those days we don't
have computer you have the technology
that technology is also in one stem
stands for science technology which is
really important in engineering image so
in my days we don't have the computers
we actually run to a library to find
anything you've got to actually browse
through the encyclopedia online
all information can be found through
your research just at a click of the
mouse but during my time we really I
spend time in the library to meet as a
student I'm quite a good student so I
move into a library so I had a
scholarship to go into teaching
after choice actually according to other
causes as well the one that interests me
the most is engineering and electronic
engineering attend far ahead of my peers
at the time there wasn't a course in the
Uni at a time electrical and electronic
engineering they only have electrical
engineering so I can't take the course
so I'm always passionate about
electronics because you use these to
make robots send some tests a future you
don't need to drive the car these days
we just press a button it goes you don't
fly the plane these days to press the
buttons openly so I'm like many years
ago I'm already interested in ODIs and
then HSC level I got the opportunity to
shake the hands of a Nobel Prize winner
you know you know who's the local price
we know of science did you know any
ladies did you know any lady there is
the most famous one
I really have a deep impression in me
she's none other than Marie Curie happy
why bother ya husband's Parekura both a
scientist so but I didn't get to shake
her hands she's you know she's died
about 15 because you got radiation she
works with radioisotope aimed she's
exposed to all these radioisotope so she
got cancer and I actually got to shake
hand with a physics Nobel Prize mean
when HSE came to visit my school that's
really great and he share the same
surname as me that's a special thing
right so that makes me really came to do
science and always very passionate to
help you people to get interested in
science and I won't bore you I think
mister who has told you why it's so
important to talk future of
hello farce and peers so I'm just gonna
introduce myself why I think science is
an important thing that you need to know
to achieve this project and also just
some interesting facts okay so let's
begin through the introduction to myself
mr. Liu and I we actually went to same
uni unfortunately our timings were a
little bit incorrect so we're never in
the same lecture theatre and I too
studied a Bachelor of education and
Bachelor of Science
but I didn't major in maths I majored in
chemistry and I was delighted to study
three years of chemistry at uni amongst
minoring and physics is also there the
two subject areas that I'm actually
capable of teaching at this school
currently I am teaching physics so
hopefully some of you I'll see you in
your land physics next year but
nonetheless I'll begin with our project
so as you're aware miss P bleakly has
already talked to you about what this
project may entail and I'll just begin
with where it all came from so when I
have to teach in k9 it's really fun
really fun and it's quite challenging to
walk from k9 all the way back to the
staff room and the quickest way is
actually through the tough playground
rather than taking the concrete path and
so I'll walk through the top playground
to arrive at either the G block or to
the staff room and during that journey
that I'll take my shoes will get really
dirty they'll get dust on them if it
rains I'll get mud on them and that was
quite irritating to me and so I'll you
know sometimes go into the top men's
toilet and just you know wiping off so
much usable clean right now they're not
clean so I don't look at them I don't
walk through the top playground and
that's the observation that I made so
I'm gonna show you a photo of an area of
the top playground you might recognize
the location does anyone know where this
is
yes oh that's G 230 you can see some
grass you can see some I don't know what
this is topsoil dirt it's terrible -
those shoes and this leads onto this
photo which is in front of G - does
anyone know where this is let's G 229 so
it's right opposite G 230 what happens
is the dirt from the G 2 30 runs off
when it rains and it cools here and so
when you want to enter this classroom if
the water through that puddle you get
mud on your feet muddy in the classroom
sleeping hazard dirty shoes no one's
happy right and so this was an issue for
me and I'm like what could we do oh we
have to do a stem project why don't you
revitalize everything that just was
fitting together and so I'm like
excellent my shoes won't get dirty we
can rejuvenate the topsoil of the top
layer and I thought it was an excellent
opportunity so that's that's kind of the
basis of where this project came about
dirty shoes and that was the observation
that I made now why is the observation
important I will show you an image
mouki remembers there SRP from me eh
remember the plan SRP project yet it
will complete those composer component
of the
and it's an introduction on the
scientific method some of you may
remember learning the scientific method
from me seven some of you may remember
from me right but I'm gonna break it
down to you because you'll be doing an
experiment that will require you to use
a scientific method what is the
scientific method
it's a procedure sort of it's a process
that allows us to answer questions
systematically and so how does it begin
I'm just gonna quickly whisk through
this is he's now our baby he's called
Kobe why I don't know it's a baby and we
start start off with the observation I
observed that my feet were getting dirty
as I was walking through the kapenga I
made that observation and then I'll form
a hypothesis does anyone remember from
me eight or u9r what our hypothesis is
yes a prediction anything else is it a
question or is it a statement statement
so it's not a question it's a statement
and a lot of people say that hypothesis
is an educated guess would you breathe
me on that elastic then they're just a
little bit further to say that a
hypothesis is making a statement with no
evidence no experimental evidence and so
that's what you'll need to do find
shortly and so I'm just gonna quickly
weave through this for time say we would
form a statement of some sort with no
experimental evidence I will perform an
experiment which you'll be doing shortly
I will analyze the data which mister
will be going through you quite
extensively because you'll be collecting
this massive data then we'll be
recording our findings now this will be
through a process of presenting a report
which I'll go through with you how to do
and then we shall invite others to
reproduce our results but because we're
a class because we're a team we'll have
many results which will be able to
someone repeat and so I'll just like to
leave you with the fact that during this
course are this project that you'll be
all participating in the scientific
method is a tool that you'll be using in
your toolbox to achieve certain outcome
and so hopefully I will go through it
together more in due course but finally
I shall leave with this image and I'm
not sure why we have mountains above but
we do and I think this is a temporary
solution to the problem that we have and
so hopefully I won't have to see this
ever again hopefully I don't have to
open it and potentially sprained my
ankle which I've almost done
oh Jesus terrible but anyways distress
but I'm sure that us the problem future
future problem solvers will be able to
deal with it so I think I've gone
through a lot but thank you very much
you know again and I think what mr. iron
has actually just left us with is
something that we've already discussed
but it also ties in very nicely so over
the last few weeks we've been going
through the steps of the design process
everyone remembers this yes they have a
nice little diagram some of us that are
brand new maybe not but we would
definitely be reiterating it in the
double period that we had last time we
got a sample brief and then we unpacked
it and we developed a research plan
that's what we're going to do with you
here today and fastened together now
that plan or that procedure
so I'm gonna show you actually this can
you show us that playing and
yes um that plan actually ties in very
nicely with the design process now we've
we've come across the design process a
couple of times now and we've identified
that the very first step is what what is
the first step in the design process
what's the very first thing that we do
we make an observation and then that
forms our design brief good can you see
exactly what we're doing here I meant
observation and then we form a
hypothesis the hypothesis is our design
brief so automatically you can see how
mr. aunt and I didn't even clean this
part of the speech but you can see that
his steps are the same as my steps okay
so we make a hypothesis and then we
perform an experiment now our experiment
if you like or we're just drawing
similarities here our process that we
need to go through is we need to do a
lot of research and then we need to come
up with a viable solution to fix all the
problems that we've identified now in
class over the last few weeks we have
gone through a lot of potential issues
of the top playground and we actually
brainstormed around and around and
around and around in circles about how
they all think so we're going to do that
again but we're going to form our
research plan Wall Street
good yeah does anybody have any
questions at this point because I'm
going to stop just for a little break
again anyone have any questions of any
of us everyone's very quiet today this
is in fact the climate and and welcome
you to the course I have a very strong
interest in the whole stem thing for a
variety of different reasons but chief
amongst them is at the beginning of last
year I was doing some work at the Board
of Studies and the board of studies
where you've got all these educators
that meet and they're the people that
set your curriculum and they set your
exams for the high school studying it
and all that sort of stuff
so at that particular meeting they were
talking about the way the world is
changing very very rapidly and the fact
that over the years we've produced a
whole lot of people who are very good at
running economies and things like that
but actually people who make things put
things together and manage them we're
starting to run out and we need to
develop a lot more people that can work
in that area and really it's in the area
of science technology engineering and
math and one of the things they talked
about was the same things where mister
we've started from is the idea that
these things should be combined and I'll
tell you I think within a couple of
years maybe even by the time some of you
people get to your HSC there will be a
new course that actually looks at
bringing all of this stuff together so
that was important for me and then I had
dinner one night with some bloke that
sir vice chancellor at the University of
Sydney and he said we've just been left
20 million dollars by a philanthropist
who knows what that big long word
philanthropist
fantastic what a great answer that's
exactly right
somebody who moves it for a given area
so fantastic answer and that money was
put aside at the University of Sydney
entirely full stem because that
particular person could see that as
being a need for our future and the way
to go and then when I was overseas last
year oh that this lovely email from mr.
Townsend saying but a horrible teacher
it's in putting together a stem class
and I thought what a great opportunity
really fantastic opportunity give you a
leg up into a whole range of different
things and a really positive way and you
know it's not just in Sydney that that's
happening and 2 o'clock yesterday
afternoon I was doing a little bit of
gardening and I came back inside and I
found that the thing was going ping ping
ping on my phone and the number of
emails have come in and one of them was
from mr. sigani from man who a school
which is a secondary Senior Secondary
School in Nagoya and we had some of
those people out visiting over there in
Nagoya they've just started a new course
for global science and really I think
this course could be almost called stem
he wanted to know whether or not we'd be
interested in having some sort of
connection with their particular school
he's talking about video conferencing
and at the moment that's as far as has
gone because a pantry or two o'clock
yesterday afternoon but I think there's
an opportunity for us to perhaps look at
what we're doing here and perhaps share
it with some folk over in Japan and you
start to see that there's a whole global
link with the stem stuff as well so it's
a good thing to get involved in I think
it's marvelous that you bring
the disciplines together and and using
them in a very positive way
and it's nice to see a nice balance of
girls and boys in me too because I think
increasingly that's something we're
starting to see in the universities as
well in the area of engineering I went
to the same university that mr. world
mr. Andy but I don't think they were
born when I went to universities there
and I used to walk through the
engineering faculty fight to make my way
up to the other side of the university
and when you walk through engineering
you never saw a woman you've never did
and and that has changed really
dramatically and flipped for the better
in a really positive way so pause there
congratulate you and welcome you on
board an official sets and say I'm
really looking forward to what's going
on